J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK. So as we
move from
radical to ionic reactions,
HOMO-LUMO
reactions, we have to take into
account solvation.
So they will do that, and
H-bonding, talk about
ionophores and Bronsted acidity.
We might begin nucleophilic
substitution.
First, the answer to that puzzle
that we had for
homework last time, the question
is how you get to the
aldehyde from the alcohol--
by free-radical chain
substitution reaction.
And do you remember that you
would substitute the hydrogen
with the chlorine, you know how
to do that.
And then if you have a base
around it-- it doesn't have to
be a strong base--
you can pull off the proton and
lose the chlorine--
chloride simultaneously in an
elimination reaction to
generate the carbonyl, and I
think a lot
of people got that.
And notice that those things
happen at the same time.
That the departure of the
chloride opens up a LUMO that
helps take the electrons from
the O-H bond.
So the O-H bond is weakened by
the fact of
the chloride leaving.
So all those things are
happening at once.
And we'll talk more when we get
to elimination reactions
about the timing of that
process.
So the base that removes the
proton could
be a very weak base.
It could be just the unshared
pair of an alcohol or even of
a bisulfate anion.
Now that might not be the way it
actually happens in 30%
sulfuric acid.
So I asked you think of another
mechanism, one
involving HOMO-LUMO
substitution.
So the question is what's the
HOMO and what's the LUMO.
So the HOMO's an unshared pair
on the alcohol, and the LUMO
is the sigma* of the
nitrogen-chlorine bond, which
is especially low because of the
positive
charge on the nitrogen.
So we can do a substitution
reaction.
And this will then put the
chlorine on to the alcohol.
The positive charge you're going
to get rid of, which you
can just do by the amine that
was generated in the same
process, it can take off the
proton, which you notice is a
substitution reaction at
hydrogen substituting nitrogen
in place of oxygen on the
hydrogen.
So then we have the same
compound as above, except the
hydrogen and the chlorine are
exchanged in their position.
So you can do the same thing
again-- bring in a base, pull
off the proton and lose the
chloride.
Now you don't usually think of
bases taking protons off from
normal carbon atoms. But this
isn't a normal carbon atom
because the chloride's leaving.
So there's something that can
take the electrons as the base
pulls the proton off.
So the same kind of elimination,
just backwards,
gives the same product.
So that was the mechanisms that
I was hoping you might be
able to see.
So in the last lecture we were
talking about what holds
molecules together other than
bonding, about non-bonded
interactions.
Those are visible in the
physical properties of the
alkyl halides in the boiling
point.
And alkanes too--
any liquid for that matter.
So we looked last time and saw
that the dipole-dipole
interaction could hold alkyl
halides together.
But that can't be all it is,
because that gets large and
then gets small again, and the
boiling points keep going up
all the time.
So there must be something else,
and that something else
is polarizability--
the fact that if you have a lot
of electrons and they're
far out in high-n orbitals so
that they're easily sloshed
around, that is, it's
polarizable, then you can have
interactions between the dipole
and something that gets
polarized by the dipole, or
indeed between two
instantaneous dipoles.
And we see that iodide here is
much more
polarizable than fluoride.
So that's the other mechanism
that's holding
the molecules together.
That is, between molecules, the
bonding between molecules,
the non-bonded interactions.
Then we said last time let's
look at hydrocarbons and see
what they tell us at butane and
isobutane, neopentane, and
n-pentane (normal pentane).
So here are the boiling points
for n-butane and isobutane.
And you see that as you make it
more branched, it's an
isomer, the same atoms. But as
you make it more branched, the
boiling point goes down.
It's easier to pull the
molecules apart to make them
in the gas phase.
The same thing is true of
pentane.
Normal pentane you go down eight
degrees to get to isopentane.
And neopentane goes down by
another 18 degrees.
So polarizability does its job
well only when things are
close together.
Remember its 1/R^N dependence,
so it falls off rapidly, the
energy you can get from this.
So if you have the same atoms,
for example, here in normal
pentane, so we got five in a
row, we have to get the atoms
close together to allow their
polarizability to hold the
molecules together.
So with these you can put them
side by side, and that's
great, and all the atoms in one
molecule are near all the
atoms in another molecule.
But if it's a branched compound
like neopentane here
where the four methyl groups are
on the same atom, then you
can't get them nearly as close
to one another for purposes of
having the polarizability do the
trick.
We have a picture here so that
you can see it better on the
next slide.
So it's atoms that are near the
surface of the molecule
that count.
Atoms that are deep down inside
of molecule don't get
close enough to their neighbors
to profit
from this very much.
So there's above n-pentane and
below neopentane, and here you
can see how much closer you can
get the molecules.
And if you'd like to see whether
you can get them
closer than I suggested in
holding here, I'll pass these
around and you can hold them and
have a good time.
Now you can see something a
little bit like that in the
heat of formation, the stability
of the molecules.
Notice that the heat of
formation of neopentane is
larger, more negative, more
downhill to form neopentane
than to form n-pentane.
Part of that must be the same
reason that the polarizability
could operate within a molecule
as
well as between molecules.
And when you get all the atoms
not to be spread out but to be
more in a ball, then the atoms
within the molecule are near
one another.
So what you lose in terms of
polarizability from one
molecule being adjacent to
another one, you gain in
interactions within the
molecule.
So that's not the only reason
for this, but that's one
reason that branching makes
molecules more stable.
So it's like solvation, except
it happens within the molecule
rather than between molecules.
And you can see the same
principle in a more pronounced
way when there's an actual
charge to do the polarizing.
So if we look here at the gas
phase ionic disassociations,
so how much energy does it take
to break a chloride away
from R to make R+.
So we look at the stability then
of the R+ cation, and
you can see that it's ever so
much easier--
53 kilocalories easier to make
t-butyl than
it is to make methyl.
Now there are a number of
factors that are involved
there and we're going to discuss
others as well.
But one of the factors is
certainly that the positive
charge gains stability by
polarizing the material
that's around it.
And the more material you have
around it, the closer to the
positive charge, the more
stability you're going to get.
So that's one of the factors
that's involved here.
It's not the only factor, but
this intramolecular
solvation--
I mean that's sort of a stupid
thing to say--
but that must be one of the
factors that helps explain
these trends.
Now here we look at the boiling
points of the normal
alkanes with different chain
lengths, and
halogen on the end.
Or in the first case, hydrogen.
So, here n-alkanes has hydrogen
on the end of the
chain, then fluoride, chloride,
bromide, iodine.
This is a picture from the
textbook, the Jones textbook,
and here we see them colored so
you can
see what atom's involved.
So one would infer from this
that for some reason--
I mean just the impression it
makes on me as a viewer is
that something suggests that the
iodides are low boiling.
You see what I'm saying?
That curve falls below the
others.
But what does molecular weight
have to do with boiling point?
Notice what's being plotted here
is molecular weight
against boiling point.
But what relevance does
molecular weight have to
boiling point?
There's sort of an intuitive
idea that if something's heavy
it's hard to get up in the gas
phase.
But that has nothing to do with
boiling point.
That's pure nonsense.
The question is is there a
better way to plot this to see
what's going on?
And I think there is, which is
instead of plot it against the
molecular weight, plot against
the length of the chain--
how big is the molecule.
So if we do that, so we plot n
here in H, CH2 taken n times,
and then X. And now we'll change
X from hydrogen the
fluorine to chlorine to bromine
to iodine.
Now fluorine is almost the same
as hydrogen.
When it's a really short chain,
the fluoride is a
little bit like-- that's methyl
fluoride--
that's higher boiling than
hydrogen.
We already explained that-- the
dipoles that are in the
CH3F can interact with one
another in a favorable way.
But once you get a real long
chain, that's not a very big
fraction of the total and it
comes to look pretty much like
the alkanes.
But now look what happens if you
go--
so the dipole moment is bigger
for fluoride than it is for
the hydrogen.
But the polarizabilities are
about the same.
But chloride is more
polarizable--
it has more electrons further
out.
So although it has essentially
the same dipole moment as the
fluoride, its polarizability,
its greater polarizability is
clearly holding things together.
And the same thing is true when
you go on to bromide,
which is still more polarizable.
And to iodide, which is the most
polarizable of all.
So in a sort of back hand way
it's related to molecular
weight, because the more
electrons you have in the
atom, the further out they are,
the more they slosh
around, the more polarizable
they are.
But the electrons have nothing
to do with the weight.
It's the nucleus that has to do
with the weight.
But more electrons mean more
neutrons and more protons in
the nucleus.
So it's sort of parallel, but I
think it's more informative
to look at it this way to see
what it is that's really
holding the molecules together.
Now you've heard the ancients
say "like dissolves like." And
you've seen things like soup
that has globs of the fat
floating around and obviously
not mixing with water.
And you've heard tell of
solvophobic forces, probably
hydrophobic forces.
So the name implies an
antagonism between water and
the alkane, the grease, that
tends to push them apart.
So you get islands of grease in
a matrix of water.
Now here're droplets of mercury
on a
cover slip, on glass.
And you can see that the mercury
beads up-- it doesn't
spread out and wet the glass.
So it seems that mercury doesn't
wet glass.
So there seems to be a phobic
force between glass and
mercury that tends to push them
apart to keep them
separate from one another.
Here we see droplets of mercury
in a polyethylene
container, and you can see that
it beads up-- that
mercury doesn't wet hydrocarbon
either.
So it looks like they are
antagonistic to one another.
The same thing is true of water.
Water doesn't wet a waxed car or
a hydrocarbon.
That's hydrophobic forces--
that's like the grease, they
stay apart.
Now, if that's so, can you tell
me should
mercury repel water?
So if we touch a drop of water
to a drop of mercury, should
they stay apart as beads or
should they
spread on each other?
How many think they should be
antagonistic and form beads?
How many think they should
spread on one another?
Well, there's a slight excess
there, but pretty close to a
tie, and I think there are a
number of
individuals not voting.
So we can do the experiment.
See how the water comes over and
grabs on to the mercury?
So clearly there's affinity
between mercury and water.
But, in fact, there's also
affinity between mercury and
glass, and there's affinity
between alkane and water.
It's a misleading term to say
"phobic" that these things are
avoiding one another.
Clearly, mercury attracts water.
But alkanes and water or mercury
and glass don't repel
one another.
There's attraction between them
as you expect.
If nothing else there will be
the mutual polarization of one
atom by another across this
boundary that will tend to
hold things together.
But mercury is particularly
good.
It has so many electrons out
there that could be
polarizable.
Mercury holds to mercury very,
very tightly.
And water likes to be near water
for hydrogen bonding,
which is what we're going to
talk about.
Water likes to be near mercury,
but not as much as
mercury likes to be near
mercury.
So water with mercury is a good
interaction from the
point of view of the water.
The water is a dipole, the
mercury is polarizable,
there's good attraction there.
But mercury doesn't want to
change its shape.
It wants to have as many mercury
atoms as close
together as possible.
It's like the alkane, the
neopentane--
the atoms want to be close to
one another
to be low in energy.
So you don't want to distort
mercury because it has so much
attraction between the atoms.
But water attracts mercury
better than it attracts itself.
So it spreads out on the
mercury.
So these solvophobic forces are
not really a question of
things being antagonistic to one
another.
It's a question of something
really wanting to be close to
itself for some particular
reason.
Mercury with mercury is very
good attraction.
But water with water, too.
Water will attract grease.
But it attracts itself much
better.
So it wants to stay connected to
itself.
This brings up the question of
what is it that
holds water to itself.
And, of course, we heard last
time about hydrogen bonding.
So let's think about hydrogen
bonding.
So water has a dipole.
So you can imagine that two of
them would line up this way--
positive to negative, the
dipoles.
But actually, this is the
calculated dimer structure for
water, calculated in 2000.
Water gets worked on so much and
it's
been worked on forever.
‘Anybody that has a theoretical
technique tries
to do it with water.
And the main thing is that
although they hold together,
they don't hold together very
strongly.
The dimerization energy's only
about three
kilocalories per mole.
And there's a lot of flexibility
in it because it's
rather weak.
But the very lowest energy,
according to this particular
calculation, is this one.
Now there's a hydrogen between
the two oxygens--
the hydrogen of one of the
molecules is
between the two oxygens.
But let's look at the bond
distances.
There's 95 picometers, that's
0.95 Å': same over here
on the left.
But the bridging one is 0.9639,
0.96.
Well, it's longer, but it's not
much longer.
So it's lengthened by only 0.5%.
So there's not much electron
pair from one oxygen donating
into sigma* of the other one--
that's what you would
expect for a bond.
It hasn't lengthened the bond to
the hydrogen.
Now, how would you expect the
waters to line up according to
their-- we looked at the charge
last time, the dipole,
but water isn't just a positive
charge here and a
negative charge here at a
certain
distance from one another.
The electrons are spread all out
with different densities.
So you can analyze it as
multipoles, not only a dipole
moment, but also a quadrupole
moment, which is plus plus
minus minus, and an octupole,
and a hexadecapole moment.
This is hard to do in your head.
But one thing you can do with
Spartan or other graphic
programs is draw this
electrostatic surface
potential that we've talked
about to see where on the
surface a proton would be happy.
That's where it's red, or
unhappy where it's blue.
And the energies are -47, very
favorable in the blue area, to
+60, very unfavorable in the red
area for a
proton at the surface.
Now let's look at the one on the
right there and let's
rotate it so we sight right
along the H-O bond.
And if we look we see that it's
blue there-- a bad place
to put a proton, a good place to
put something negative.
And the color scale here goes
instead of -47 to 60, well
this is -45 to 60.
But we can home in on it to get
the colors to show what we
want by going +55 to +60.
Now you see that there's a very
small region there which
is the best place to put
something negative, the worst
place to put something positive.
And if we look at it we see that
as you move the proton up
and down there or back and
forth, you change by half a
kilocalorie per mole if you go
up and down by half an
angstrom, which would correspond
then if you went up
there-- that's where we're
looking at on the surface.
So that's plus or minus 9
degrees up and down.
So that's a fairly tiny target,
although it doesn't--
half a kilocalorie isn't
enormous.
You could go further and not
lose too much.
But look at the oxygen end.
If we rotate that one and look
at the water from the oxygen
end, we see there's a very big
streak of red.
That's 10 kilocalories total
range on the color scale.
If we go here down to 5, which
is the same scale being used
over here, it's way spread out.
And even if we go further to
only one and a half
kilocalories per mole, for the
entire color scale you can see
that that red range goes quite
far up and down, 1.38
Å', plus or minus 25 degrees.
And the energy change is only
0.05.
So it's very big red target that
you can tolerate.
So you have a tall target there
and a small target on
the other one.
Now when you put them together
this way you see you can bend
these down and get these
hydrogens far away from that
one and still have very good
contact between the places
that complementary charges are
good to sit.
That's a very qualitative sort
of analysis of this, but it's
a sort of funny minimum energy
structure for water.
But the important thing is that
it's consistent with just
how the charges of isolated
waters would interact with one
another, just charge-charge
interaction.
There's no special bonding.
Quantum mechanics didn't come
into this.
Once you have the water
molecules you'd bring them
together and that's a reasonable
way for them to fit.
The disassociation energy is not
large. It's 3.3
kilocalories per mole, but you
can get other
waters around and about.
So taking a water molecule into
the gas phase out of
water is much more, of course,
than 3 kilocalories per mole.
So from this perspective what
makes hydrogen bonding
important is that you have these
dipoles, but they can
get very close to one another,
because remember the energy
falls off very rapidly with
distance.
Because hydrogen is so small it
can get very close to the
oxygen end of a dipole.
So it's just dipole-dipole
interaction like you have in
any of these other things we
were looking at, but they can
get really, really close to one
another.
So you get more energy in the
case of hydrogen bonds than
you do for other dipoles.
So nothing special.
There's no real bonding to it.
It's just that the molecules can
come together and be low
in energy that way.
Typically, the hydrogen bonding
is less than 5%, often
much less than 5% as strong as a
covalent bond.
So a hydrogen bond isn't
anything like the bonds we
talked about last semester.
Or is it?
A hydrogen bonding can be
subtle.
And it's the subject of
continuing investigation.
There's a Professor Johnson, a
physical chemist in our
department, is doing a lot of
work on the
structure of water.
And Professor Jorgensen, a
theoretician, has done a lot
of work on water as well.
So if you have ions involved, so
not neutral waters coming
together, but the protonated
water coming together with the
water, then the question is what
kind of hydrogen bonding
are you going to get in this
case?
Now the heat involved in those
things coming together,
instead of 3.3 kilocalories per
mole is 10 times greater.
32 kilocalories per mole.
But, of course, there's an
entropy price to pay when you
pull these things together.
So the actual free energy change
in bringing them
together isn't nearly as
favorable because you're
localized in things that were
free to move around before.
So the free energy change at 300
kelvin is 8 kilocalories
per mole in the gas phase.
But here's what's interesting.
There's the structure of this
H5O2+'.
What do you notice about it as
compared to the water dimer?
STUDENT: I think it's bonded.
PROFESSOR: Why do you think so,
Lauren?
Why do you think it's bonded?
STUDENT: Because the lines are
going both ways.
It looks like it's sitting right
in the middle of it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The hydrogen is right in the
middle.
It's not like the other one
where the hydrogen was a
normal bond distance from one
oxygen and quite far
from the other one.
It's right in the middle.
And in fact, if you do a
calculation of how much energy
it takes to move that hydrogen
back and forth, you see that
it's a single minimum.
Not a double minimum where it
could be part of the time on
one, part of the time on the
other and jump back and forth.
It's a single minimum.
The H+ is equally shared.
So this case is real bonding.
A single minimum in the middle.
Now, how about if we do the
anion example--
H3O2-‘, hydroxide being hydrogen
bonded by water.
So what's the answer there?
We know that the energy involved
is rather similar to
what it is for the H5O2--
it's 27 kilocalories per mole in
the gas phase.
But the structure is rather
different, or is it?
Is the hydrogen halfway in
between?
What do you notice about this
one compared to the cation?
It a double minimum now, not a
single minimum.
So it's lower in energy when the
hydrogen is on
one end or the other.
And a maximum, local maximum, in
the middle.
However, hydrogen is very light.
What does that have to do it?
Go back to the beginning of last
semester.
STUDENT: Tunneling?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: Tunneling.
If you look at the very lowest
energy level for moving the
hydrogen back and forth, you'll
see something
interesting.
So this is a double minimum.
The hydrogen is not
symmetrically bound along this.
But it can't have the minimum
energy.
And the barrier is very low,
only 0.6
kilocalories per mole.
So if you look at the lowest-
energy vibrational wave
function, it looks like that.
So even though it's a double
minimum, the hydrogen spends
most of its time in the middle.
And, of course, the reason it
can do that is that--
the reason it can spend most of
its time in the middle is
because there is some bonding
that lowers its energy there.
So there can be hydrogen
bonding.
We saw it in H3O+ plus water.
We see it in hydroxide plus
water.
Even though it's a double
minimum in potential energy,
the thing can be in the middle.
So there is real bonding there.
And in fact, in pure water
without ions, if you have high
pressure that forces the waters
closer together, so the
better part of a million
atmospheres--
and this can be done in a
laboratory--
the oxygens get closer together
and closer together.
What was a double minimum
becomes a single minimum.
And the structure of this Form
10 of ice--
water is nothing if not
versatile.
There are more than 10 different
structures of ice
that have been observed.
But this particular high
pressure one, as you can see
from the structure, has
hydrogens halfway between.
So it's no longer molecular
water.
It's an entire crystal-- the
whole thing is one molecule
with hydrogen bonds holding it
together.
But this is not what we usually
are talking about in
terms of hydrogen bonds.
Normal hydrogen bonds are just
this polar interaction which
are favorable because hydrogen's
so small and can
get close to other things.
Now we're going to go on from
this digression about water to
talk about crown ethers, and
what are called tailored
ionophores.
So here's a crown ether.
You have to be imaginative to
see that as a crown.
But you can sort of imagine
putting it on your head and
have all the little things go up
and around, and I suppose
that's where the name came from.
So this idea of having an oxygen
and then a bridge of
two carbons and another oxygen
and a bridge,
oxygen, bridge in a ring.
Those are the crowns.
So they have a name, this is
18-crown-6.
So it's a crown alternating
oxygen and two carbons, oxygen
and two carbons.
And it's six because there are
six oxygens in it.
And this was one of the earliest
ones studied.
And in fact, these crown ethers
resulted in the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry for the
people who discovered and
exploited them in 1987.
Ionophore means an ion carrier--
the Greek root phorous means to
carry things.
So these things are able to
carry ions--
let's see how that works.
So here's 18-crown-6 viewed from
the top and from the side
with potassium chloride.
And you see the potassium is
held inside.
I'll pass this around so you can
see it.
Here's the ring of 6 oxygens
connected by
pairs of CH2 groups.
It turned out that a golf ball
is about the right scale to
have the radius of a potassium
ion on the
scale of these models.
And you see it fits right in the
middle.
If we look at the 6 oxygens,
they're not all in a plane, as
you can see there.
There are three of them up and
three of them down.
Does that remind you of
anything?
Megan?
STUDENT: Cyclohexane.
PROFESSOR: Just like
cyclohexane--
it goes up down, up down, up
down, the chair cyclohexane.
And the potassium sits right in
the middle with three above
and three below, and I'll pass
that around so you can see it.
So potassium is just the right
size to fit in there-- fits
right in the middle.
If we look at the actual
distances that are involved
you can see these distances are
all about 2.8 Å',
which is just about exactly the
sum of the ionic radii of
potassium and the covalent
radius of oxygen--
2.7 that would be.
Those numbers aren't really such
great numbers, so that it
really fits right.
Now what if you use a bigger ion
like cesium?
So cesium is 1.7 Å', so now 3.1
instead of 2.7 for the
oxygen-cesium distance.
Now you can see that because
cesium's larger it can't get
in the middle; it sits on top
close to three of the oxygens,
and further from the bottom
three oxygens.
There's the view from the back.
Now here's the skeleton with the
balls for
the atoms of that.
And you can see that the closer
oxygens are at van der
Waals distance, 3.1 Å'. But the
others are closer to
3.2 or 3.3 Å'.
Now that distance is 4.8 Å'.
What happens if you
would make an even smaller ion
in the middle?
You could try to shrink the ring
down.
But if you pull those two closer
together in order to
make all five of these closer to
whatever's in the middle,
then that one's going to get
squeezed out.
So here's what happens if you go
to sodium.
And now that distance is 4.0,
roughly an angstrom closer in
order to get these close to the
sodium.
Sodium to oxygen is 2.4.
So that sixth one got squeezed
out, but it
came in from the bottom.
So if we look at the distances,
those are all in
the neighborhood of 2.4, 2.5,
one is 2.6, so just a little
bit bigger than the van der
Waals distance.
And the one on the bottom is
2.4, so it squeezes underneath
and is just happy.
But it leaves space on the top,
and this particular
crystal structure had a water in
it.
So the water is up on top at
2.32 Å'.
If we get smaller still with
lithium, now the lithium can't
shrink the ring down anymore.
It gets close to just two of
them, 2.2 Å'--
notice that's 2.1 and 2.1, 2.07.
But it's further from the
others.
And notice it sits right in the
middle of the mean plane
of these things.
But what happens with
interactions
with the far oxygens?
This one has two waters.
So the waters bind to the
lithium, and then the protons
of the water are hydrogen bonded
to those far oxygens.
So lithium increases its size by
incorporating two waters
with it, so it can fit in this
thing.
Now look at the equilibrium
constant for binding the
cations to this 18-crown-6.
Notice that potassium is by far
the biggest. So
these are too big--
we looked at cesium.
Sodium and lithium were too
small, but
potassium is just right.
So when this is 1 this is 60
times bigger.
Now the equilibrium constant is,
of course, the
concentration of the complex
divided by the concentrations
of the metal ion and the ligand
product.
So it has units expressed this
way, it's per molar.
And if you look at the actual
value, not just relative to
one another which was what's
plotted first but the actual
value, you see that it's over a
million,
this equilibrium constant.
Now let's think of what that
means.
That one's 23,000.
So what this means is that when
the
ligand, down here, equals--
when the ligand times K is 1,
then you have 50%
that this is 1:1.
If you multiply this over here
and that comes out to 1, then
you have the same amount of
metal that's uncomplexed as
you have of metal that's
complexed.
So what that means is that it's
half complexed when you
have 1 µM of concentration of
the ligand.
So it holds on very, very
tightly.
Now, bear in mind that there's
something else that could
complex with the potassium ion.
The methanol solvent could do
so.
This is done in methanol solvent
at room temperature.
Now methanol is 0.79 g/mL.
Its molecular weight is 32.
So we can calculate what its
concentration is.
Its concentration is 25 M. So
the ligand, at 1 µM',
is able to beat out methanol at
25 M. So it's 29 million
times stronger than methanol at
binding to this by having
all these six arranged so they
grab it just right, it fits
just right.
The energy involved is 13
kilocalories per mole of
stabilization.
Again, nothing compared to
covalent bonds
that we talked about.
But it's much more favorable in
the case of a potassium
than it is in the case of
sodium, just 5
kilocalories less.
But notice what this does when
you put this crown
around the golf ball.
It makes it much bigger.
But what holds a salt together
is the attraction between the
cation and the anion, which
depends very much on distance.
So if you make the ions bigger,
as we mentioned in the
last lecture, they won't
interact so strongly.
So it's not so stable to be in
the solid salt form.
It's easier to dissolve.
So you can dissolve potassium
permanganate in hydrocarbons
if you use crown ether to put in
there to make the potassium
ever so much bigger.
So this has worked out in lab in
a way that's shown here.
So you have some organic
solvent, and you put something
in it that you want to oxidize.
So you need an oxidizing agent--
ah, potassium permanganate.
So we have an organic substance
to be oxidized, and
we put in potassium
permanganate, and it just sits
on the bottom of the flask.
It doesn't get to where the
organic molecules are, so
there's no reaction.
And if you put water in, that
will dissolve the potassium
permanganate, but it won't get
the potassium permanganate
where the organic stuff to be
oxidized is.
It'll just be two phases.
A purple phase-- a water phase
that has the permanganate in
it, and then the organic phase
just floating above it.
But if you put in the crown
ether, then the permanganate
can dissolve in the organic
solvent and can do the trick.
So by making the cation large,
18-crown-6 destabilizes a
solid, or aqueous permanganate,
allowing the
salt to dissolve in
hydrocarbons.
And people call this purple
benzene.
I actually have never done this
and never seen purple
benzene, but Professor Ziegler
has done it, and he tells me
that purple benzene prepared
this way isn't purple at all,
it's yellow.
So that's just his one
experiment.
So I don't know that it's never
purple, but that's what
he told me.
So maybe purple benzene looks
sort of yellow, according to
Professor Ziegler.
That would just be because
permanganate in an organic
solvent has a different spectrum
from permanganate in
water solvent, which wouldn't be
surprising.
But it works.
People are able to do oxidations
this way.
And it's called phase transfer
catalysis, because the idea is
to get a reagent from one phase
into the other.
You use the crown ether as a
catalyst. It doesn't get
consumed, it just helps the
stuff get there and do its
reaction in the other phase, so
it's catalysis.
And you don't have to use crown
ethers for this,
although they are used for it.
You can get a similar effect by
having other really big
cations that make it possible
for an anion to go into the
organic phase.
So tetraalkylammonium or
tetraakylphosphonium salts.
The advantage of these things is
that there are solvents
that will dissolve both organic
things and potassium
permanganate, or other salt
reagents.
But those salts [correction:
solvents], like dimethyl
sulfoxide that will do that,
are dangerous and they're
expensive.
So this is an example of green
chemistry--
to do chemistry in a more
environmentally favorable way
by using these ethers or simple
salts as a way of
getting the reagents to mix.
Now a further development on
this is called cryptands,
which you notice is like a crown
ether, except that it
has a nitrogen in it which is
trivalent rather than oxygen
being divalent.
So you can get another bridge
across.
So you can get these crypts into
which to hide things.
So here's an example of a
cryptand.
And Jean-Marie Lehn who did this
work with Jean-Pierre
Sauvage, got the Nobel Prize for
this-- shared the Nobel
Prize for these crown ethers.
So now you can put different
numbers of these OCH2CH2
groups in here.
So you can make different sizes
for these rings.
So here is an example of where
l is 1, so you have 1 bridge
that has two oxygens, and two
bridges that have one oxygen,
and I've made a model of that
here.
So you see there are two oxygens
here on the top, but
there's one on this way and one
here.
And two nitrogens also point in
with their lone pairs.
So that makes a pretty small
cavity inside.
I'll pass that one around to
you.
You won't be surprised to hear
then that when you look at the
equilibrium constant in methanol
for putting various
salts in there, that lithium is
the one that binds most
strongly, the smallest of the
ions.
It has an ionic radius of a
little less than
three-quarters of an angstrom.
So it fits, but sodium doesn't
fit as well, potassium's bad.
And these are whited out
because, in fact, they were
measured but they come way down
off the
bottom of this graph.
And now if you make one of the
other bridges have two oxygens
in it, so you increase the size
of the hole a little bit,
now it binds with sodium the
best. And if you put the other
bridge bigger it binds potassium
the best. And if you
put two carbons in one of the
bridges, it binds rubidium the
best. If you put two carbons in
all the bridges it binds
cesium best. And I put
cesium-137 here because that's
a by-product of isotope
enrichment in nuclear
industry, and it's a common
pollutant that they want to
get rid of.
So what they're trying to do now
is to design cryptands
that will readily bind to
cesium, so you can take the
earth or these million gallon
barrels that have this waste
stuff in them.
Put something in that will
specifically get the cesium,
which is the worst actor among
these radioactive by-products.
That'll take them, put it in
another phase, and then make
it reversible so that you can
take the cryptand
off and use it again.
So there's a lot of work being
done on that
kind of thing now.
But this also could be used in
biology.
For example, there's a bacterial
antibiotic called
nonactin, which you see is a
ring that has a lot
of oxygens in it.
Now that ring is quite a big
one, but you can curl it
around like this, as I show
here--
bend those ends up.
And then the chain looks like
the seams on a tennis ball.
But you have all these oxygens
that can then be directed
toward the middle.
So here's a picture of that
wrapped around a cation.
Now it's not easy to see the
three dimensions here, but if
you let it rotate you can see
what the shape is of this
thing that's wrapped completely
around the
potassium ion with 8 oxygens
coordinated to the potassium.
And there you can see the seams
on a tennis ball, which
trace this chain.
And the equilibrium constant in
methanol for holding on to
sodium is 512.
But for potassium, the one
that's shown there, it's
31,000, so it's very selective.
It's even tighter with ammonium
in the middle.
So how do these things work in
biology?
I don't know, but the general
idea is that they can make
ions dissolve in organic things.
So the potential in your cells
has to do with pumping sodium
and potassium ions back and
forth and creating a gradient.
And if you suddenly put
something in that'll say to
potassium, you can go wherever
you want.
That destroys this and it's bad
for living things.
So anyhow, biology has a number
of things that can do
this kind of trick with ions as
well.
Now the next topic is the
importance of solvent for
ionic reactions.
And I'm going to start this
since we started
a little bit late.
But we'll complete it next time.
So we're interested in the
reaction, a water molecule
surrounded by water, in water
solvent, dissociating to give H+
and O-H-.
And we want to know what
energy's going to
be involved in that.
What will the equilibrium
constant be.
And I think you people know the
equilibrium constant from
your AP chemistry.
But we're going to look at it a
different way as to what's
involved, what role the solvent
plays in this.
So the way we're going to do it
is to look at it without
solvent by going into the gas
phase.
So if we pump in 6.3
kilocalories per mole, we can
make the water that's in water
become water in the gas phase.
And now we know we can look up
in Ellison's table a bond
dissociation energy for water
and find that it's going to
take 120 kilocalories per mole
to get it apart to H atom and
O-H radical
And then if we transfer an
electron from one to the
other, that's then going to get
us the species we're
interested in, but in the gas
phase.
That's 392 kilocalories per mole
in toto to do those
three things.
And remember the Coulomb energy
is the gorilla in this
particular scheme.
It's that 332 kilocalories
divided by angstroms. So
that's the big one is that
electron transfer and getting
the ions apart.
So the equilibrium constant in
the gas phase is 10^-290--
not a very favorable process.
But we know that it can happen
in water.
So the solvent has a lot to do
with it, and we'll talk about
that next time.